Rosie, it's almost time to go.
I know
Okay, but before we do,
we have one more surprise for two people in our audience.
That's right. Drew.
Okay. Where is Malachi Barnett?
Right here. Hi
(Audience applause)
How you doing sir?
(Rosie) Hi.
Hi, you're a fireman also, right, from Tulsa?
Yes ma'am
(Rosie) Aww.
(crowd cheering and applauding)
Look at that
Malachi, um
we heard, okay you're in your dream job.
You're looking for your dream girl.
Um, Is this true?
Yes. Ma'am very much so.
(Rosie) Very much so
(Drew) Oh Gosh, thank God.
Well you know, we love, love around here right?
So we're always trying to hook people up.
So I'm just curious.
Where is Shadia?
(Drew) Yeah, Shadia
Right here
(Rosie) Oh, you're right there.
Oh,
Hello.
(Rosie) Well look who you're sitting next to.
(Drew) Yes.
A little birdie told us that
you just happened to be single, right?
I happen to be.
(Rosie) You happened to be.
(Drew) Thank goodness.
(Rosie) Yeah.
And random question.
What are your thoughts on men in uniform?
They're the best. Like I just...
I want a man in uniform.
Well, Malachi meet Shadia.
Shadia, little Birdie told me that
Malachi was featured in the
2021 Tulsa Firefighter's Calender.
(crowd cheering and applauding)
We thought that maybe, perhaps
we could send you guys on a blind date,
which now is not so blind.
(Rosie) Uh oh.
That would be awesome.
Sounds amazing.
(Drew and Rosie cheering)
Um, all right.
Well, um.
If you don't mind,
we'd like to check in and see how it goes.
Not at all, not at all.
It's all right, go ahead.
Okay. Well, at a certain point,
maybe we'll have some information and
if, and then you can go to the Drew Barry more Show
and find out some highlights possibly,
but we'll see, we'll just see how it goes.
(Rosie) We'll see how it goes
Um, enjoy,
and just know we're sending you good well-wishes
and cozy vibes.
And basically to every single person
who came here in this audience.
That's exactly what we are wishing and giving to you.
Heart and goodness.
I promise you, we make the show for you
and we just want you to take it with you.
(upbeat music)